hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trendsenses.com
so this is youtube so let me quickly
introduce myself for those who are
watching my video for the first time
i'm a professional trader and i've been
using technical analysis
for the past six years to make money on
the markets and i'm here to show you
guys how i do it and all the different
tools and techniques that work the best
for me
and most importantly i want you guys to
be able to do it yourself
so in today's video i want to make a
complete analysis of amc
and see what my tools are giving me
let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys so this is amc let's
start on the fourth time frame
as usual and let's do a bit of idiot
wave counting
first and then let's zoom in a little
bit and see what kind of signals we can
find on the shorter term
so the first thing let me just quickly
show you guys what i'm doing here so
move up all right
the first here then correction in here
so this is a bit disgusting up
my correction is like this abc guys
moves up developing five waves move down
develop in three ways all right so this
is my move down
let me put it in green all right and
right now we are having
this new move up but it is not happening
right now we're waiting for a third wave
so this is what we're looking for
one two three four five and
then i think we're gonna go to 35 and
this is only gonna be our third wave
then we're gonna correct and probably go
higher but this would take a bit of time
guys first
here we're wondering what is happening
on the shorter term so as i said this is
only a second wave
of this one two three four five that is
happening here
and we are trying to guess when it's
going to be complete
so we need to understand what kind of
correction we have in here and i was
telling you this guys uh many times
already before
i was expecting a wxy correction to take
place
here so we are having our abc that is
the w wave
we having another abc that is x wave
and right now guys we have a few
scenarios possible so let me discuss it
with you
so we need a y to take place why
waves can be flat triangles or zigzag
so let's do the three scenarios all
right
so my first scenario is that we would
have zigzag
so we had the a wave here i was telling
you guys in my previous videos that we
are going to have some bullishness
coming back here
actually on the earnings so very quickly
the earnings you know
were quite good so amc was up eight
percent blah blah blah
reported first quarter 2021 financial
results thursday night
so aaron who is the ceo said the company
now has about one third of the u.s
market so basically they have more
market share
we finally can now say that we're
looking at an increasingly favourable
environment for movie going and for amc
as a company over the coming few months
the revenue is still down blah blah amc
is not yet back to profitability but the
company has raised a lot of capital we
know that
to navigate through the balance of this
crisis with enough cash on hand news
that it has gained market share during
the downturn and an environment where
consumers are going back
out you know after the crisis investors
may be ready to believe
there will be a long-term positive
outcome for amc so this is you know the
bullishness we're having here
that you know i was expecting so of
course you have a news that helps us but
we would have this b wave anyways guys
that's how you know the price action is
developing
and right now we're wondering what is
happening here so like i said we can
have an abc
so the typical b wave would go to the
open
38.2 retracement level so you know
one minus the number so it would go to
the 1030 area
all right and then we would have a c
wave that would probably go
we have two levels here so this is kind
of the bearish case
either we go to the bottom of the w wave
so it's around 8 30
or we go even lower but it's not my
preferred scenario to the bottom of the
force wave here so we have two levels
possible if we have an abc
830 or 750. so this is the bearish
case now we could have a flat so if it's
a flat correction the b wave
goes much higher and just comes back
here
we could have a flat as a y wave as well
so that's why it's very interesting to
see how much bullishness there's going
to be
here so a flat is an abc but the b wave
you need to go at least to the 0.786
fib retracement level so it's 1150 and
if we go to this level
then the c wave would probably just go
around
the bottom of the wave a so it's around
nine
so this would give us some precious
information depending how strong the
rebound would be at the beginning of
next week because i believe strongly
that amc would go higher
even if it's only a b wave you're gonna
feel some bullishness coming back and
then we're gonna have the c wave
unfortunately
this is a bit to me inevitable but let's
see where the b wave is going
and one more scenario that is also very
likely guys is that we're having a
triangle
and i'm going to show you why i think
the triangle is actually the
most likely scenario so a
b c d e you know we would have something
like this
okay and this would be my y
wave let me show you why guys you just
type idiot wave thrust and pressure on
google
you take the second link and you find
this
pdf here that is the pdf of the book
that is containing so much precious
information guys if you want to know
more click on the link in the
description of this video i
did a sum up using nice examples and
you know just giving you for me the most
important information about this book
so if you want to know more just click
on the on this link but here look what
it's saying so it's talking about double
threes and triple threes so exactly what
we are having here some
sideways combination of corrective
patterns all right
so this is what we're having here guys
wxy
it's exactly this and he's saying
recall that triangles occurring alone
precede the final movement
of larger trend combinations appear to
recognize this character
and sport triangles only as the final
wave in a double or triple three
so what it means is that usually at the
end of a triple three
you have a triangle exactly like we have
on sorry this is gamestop
you see exactly like we're having on
gamestop actually so that's why i expect
kind of the same
uh complex correction to take place here
so a triangle here would make sense
so we're going to see if we have a
triangle after a
b so let me put it a different color
guys i can put it in yellow
so after we having the b wave and if the
c wave
rebounds here you know around this level
and we see this contraction that is
happening with the realized volatility
that is going lower you know
then we would know we have a triangle so
we can play the g the g
wave and the e wave and we having some
very good information that
everything looks fine and that this is
just a sideways complex correction
and that we're gonna have the third wave
coming so this would be
i don't know when guys let's be honest
maybe around the 25th of may if i look
at this
so once again i sum up what i've just
said here guys we having a y
wave that is taking place and we have
three levels for this
y wave either so the most bearish one we
go to 750
i don't believe it or we go to 830 by
doing a zigzag
why not and we can see that here we're
having a 10 30 the 200
moving average coming as well so it
makes sense for our field retracements
so this is a very useful scenario so we
go to 10 20 we correct we go to 8 30.
bearish case then the other case is we
do a flat so we come back here
like this bam bam bam all right then we
go higher or we do a triangle which i
just showed you guys
and the triangle would be the most
bullish one and it would be the one i
would prefer to see guys because
like you've just seen written in the
book
here the triangles are usually the last
you know something like this
the last corrective patterns in a
sideways correction of combinations of
corrective patterns
that is preceding the next move up so
that's it for me i hope you guys enjoyed
this video and if you did please don't
forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're going to
be the first to know when i upload
anything
new and stay close to show see you guys